Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to our session, Researcher Town Hall:
Navigating Policy Challenges and Securing Funding.
It's been a great meeting so far. Who was at that amazing opening ceremony
today? Just so fantastic. But we keep having
to work to make sure that we can fund our initiatives, that we have
bipartisan support. There are some challenges, and this
panel today will really help us to understand what we're
dealing with and how we can work together to fight
for cancer research, which saves lives. I'm Roy Herbst.
Currently, I'm the Ensign Professor of Medicine and the Chief of Hematology
Oncology at Yale Cancer Center. I'll be moving this summer to
become the Director at the Dartmouth Cancer Center in Hanover, New Hampshire.
Here are my disclosures.
Well, what is the impact of policy on cancer research?
And one of the things that's just been so exciting to me as the
chair for a number of years now of the Scientific Policy and Government Affairs
Committee of the AACR, is the great team we have here that's
really working to spread the word about how policy impacts our
work. Cancer research is at a critical moment.
There are such rapid scientific advances. Just walk down these two halls.
Every room has something new and exciting.
The data from pancreatic cancer that were at the press conference this morning,
KRAS and lung cancer, just to name a few, and that's just the very first thing out
of the meeting. Rapid policy change and funding uncertainty
is important. And that's affecting everyone
here. You hear those discussions throughout the meeting.
Federal government policy decisions are directly affecting who and what
gets funded,
who is in the workforce, we have to continue to build and nurture our workforce,
and how our research is conducted.
Now, there's a shifting federal funding landscape.
The federal administration policies and actions have led to widespread disruptions
to grants and clinical trials in 2025.
Continued delays in grant funding dispersal.
If the money doesn't get out to the sites, it can't be used.
It's hard to hire someone if you don't have the money in the bank.
Proposal to use over half of the NIH budget for multi-year funding.
I guess that's good if you've got the multi-year funding, but what about all the
other grants that can't be funded that year because it's reduced significantly the
number of grants that can get funded, and shifting research priorities.
And those, we need to know what those are. We'll talk about that.
How do we know what the priorities are so that we can target the best ones?
So, the NIH announced overall reduction in the number of NIH Notices of
Funding Opportunity. We call those in the field
NOFOs. Moving toward broad parent announcements
for unsolicited or investigator-initiated applications.
So if they don't put out the notice of award, it's hard to know what to target.
There's a new unified NIH funding strategy.
Removal of pay lines.
Okay.
So then what will get funded? Are there appropriate people in place
to grade and to determine what gets funded?
These are all concerns that we have. We'll talk about it.
Much of this is done by political appointees for review and
approval. And you can see in the bottom right, the number of notices of
awards has gone down dramatically in this
year.
These are just some of the policy changes that have hit us.
I'm at an academic medical center.
I bet many of you are, our panelists are.
And
in January of this year, a new simplified review framework became
effective.
Okay, but again, it changes the target, and we're shooting
at it with grants. In March, announcement of centralization of peer review,
so not being done at the NCI, but in a central location.
Concerns, will there be the right reviewers?
Will there be the expertise to review our work?
Removal of diversity plans and reports across all funding mechanisms.
So a total reversal of what had been in place.
I had several grants personally. I had to scrub those grants and change the
wording.
Again, a change that we had to deal with.
In April, announced prioritization of human-based research technologies,
meaning fewer studies with mouse models and
other non-human models. So we'll talk about this on the panel.
In May, there's a new announcement of foreign subaward structure,
making it harder to do work in a global way with foreign
partners. In November, the announcement of implementation of a unified NIH funding
strategy. So again, NCI always had its own special way of
doing it, so we have to adapt to that.
There were modifications to peer review, and in
January of this year, a shift away from human fetal tissue
research. That's always been a hot button issue over the years, but it's certainly
a source of discovery.
So here you can see some
things that are really critical. We all have trainees.
We want these trainees to come work in this country.
We want the brains of science to be here to work with us
in our labs, in our clinics. And then there's a $100,000 fee on
H-1B visas. That's a lot of money, and it already was hard to get
an H-1B visa, but this is a concern.
There's a falling early stage investigator funding rates.
If you're only funding grants in the
4% range for all investigators perhaps, or less than
10% or 11% for early investigators, it's a problem.
This causes career instability.
People wonder, "Should I stay in science?
Should I go find a job elsewhere?" And the loss of training programs.
And you can see
the R01 equivalent applications.
You can see they're going up, but awardees are going down.
So the blue shows the number of applications go up, the red shows the amount of
funding goes down. And it's hard. I think what it would be like for me 25,
30 years ago, waiting for that first K award or R01
and not getting it the first time or the second time, being worried about that,
having to support
family and others. It's a
problemDisparities is at
a crossroads. There's
many health disparities that remain.
I was just at a cancer center directors meeting a few minutes ago.
We were talking about the disparities among the nation.
Higher cancer mortality, underserved, and rural populations.
There was a talk, based on your ZIP code, you might have different
results in your care. Gaps in access to screening,
early detection, and innovative therapies.
We talked about this on a panel on Saturday, that people have to have access to
these new drugs, these new therapies, to screening, to samples, to determine
the right therapy. Policy shifts are reshaping
disparities research. Staffing cuts and removal of
equity related initiatives is
happening. Termination of grants focused on health disparities and
DEI. People have literally been told, "Your grant is no longer funded."
And prioritization of solution-oriented approaches in health disparities
research. Certainly, solution-oriented approaches are good, but these
things have to be done in a staged and systematic way.
So advocacy and researcher engagement.
I'm so happy to see all of you here late in the day on a Sunday.
We need to engage in policy conversations and communicate this to
our policymakers. Like we all held up the signs this morning, right?
Everybody see that at the opening ceremony.
Work across disciplines and provide input into policy generation.
There are many ways to engage, and you're going to hear from John in a moment, who
is the best I know at telling us what's going on and what to do next.
Stay informed on policy developments.
Build relationships with policymakers and staff.
Cancer is not political, it's personal.
It doesn't matter if you're a Democrat or Republican, you're going to get cancer.
Your friends will get cancer. We need to cure cancer, and we actually just heard
that from the NCI director earlier, that everyone wants
to cure cancer. It's just, how do we do it as a team?
Participating in advocacy days and collaborating with professional society
coalitions and patient advocacy groups.
In September, there'll be a big research day on The Hill.
Many of those of us in the cancer centers are going up to a Hill day, May
13th. These are all things that are important.
So we have put together to discuss this, and I'm just so excited about it, just the
most tremendous panel, and I thank them all for coming here today.
I'll introduce them all now, and then they'll each have about five minutes to give
you some opening remarks. And then what I really hope will happen today is you'll
come to the microphones, or if you would rather just send me the question, you can
do that,
and we'll take questions. I also have a few questions I'll start us out with to get
the discussion going. But it's going to be really great.
The first speaker is going to be John Retzlaff, who's the Chief Policy Officer, the
Vice President of Science, Policy, and Government Affairs for the AACR.
Then you're going to hear from Nelly Oricć.
She's the Chief Scientific Officer and Executive Director of the Comprehensive
Cancer Center, Huntsman Cancer Institute, in Utah.
And she's very involved in a number of really high-ranking
government committees and the AACI, incoming president in a year.
So she'll tell us a lot about what her perspective is. Then you'll hear from Dr.
John Wherry, who's the most amazing translational scientist, Chair of the
Department of Systems Pharmacology and Translational Therapeutics at the University
of Pennsylvania, sort of really leading the immunology revolution and many other
things. And then, of course, the most important, Patty Spears, because
we're going to get the patient voice.
It's about how do we treat patients, and she's the Research Manager
of the Patient Advocates for Research Council, the Office of Community Outreach and
Engagement at the Lineberger Cancer Center.
Of course, that's in North Carolina.
So it's my pleasure to have you all here today.
And now I'm going to turn it over to John to tell us what's going on and what we
need to do. John.
All right.
All right. Thanks so much, Roy, and really in response to your final slide
regarding how we just cannot afford to be sitting on the sidelines,
I'm thrilled to really take people through how AACR responded
over the past year. When we saw the administration's proposals to
cut NIH funding by 40%, which would have been a $20
billion cut. Many of you remember that from last year.
They were terminating grants, terminating advisory councils, and
terminating NIH employees. So
start taking you through...
Uh-oh. Am I going the wrong way?
Maybe you should look which way we have to go. Is it right or left?
Here we go. Okay, there we go.
It's a good review.
All right.
All right. Well, let's start out. So we focused on Congress.
They control the power of the purse.
So we knew we had to put all our efforts into convincing members of Congress that
they needed to push back on this president's crazy budget to cut
NIH by 40%. We also issued many public statements
in opposition to the president's proposals and everything.
We needed to engage all of AACR members and the broader community,
general public, to support cancer research and medical science.
And we worked
collectively with 400 plus organizations who are part of the
medical research advocacy community.
That was what we set out to do from the beginning.
And early on, we found out that the Republicans in
Congress were unwilling to push back on the president's budget.
They were unwilling to hold hearings or anything like that to talk about what was
going on. Fortunately,
the Democrats,
all they could do was a Congressional forum, they called it.
Because Republicans controlled the House and Senate, they weren't
going to do a Congressional hearing on this.
So we did what was called a Congressional forum.
AACR had a witness as part of that. We had someone from
ALS, Alzheimer's, and it was a very successful
hearing to show what was happening, or potentially going to happen, to
the medical research enterprise if something wasn't done to push back on the
president's proposals.
We recognized members of Congress.
Many of you, if you were here last year, you remember that we presented the AACR
Public Service Award to Senators Baldwin and Shelley
Moore Capito, both the Republican and Democratic leaders on
the Senate Labor, HHS Appropriation Subcommittee, which provides
money to NIH funding.You want to recognize members of
Congress for the things they're doing.
We sounded the alarm at last year's annual meeting, had the former NIH director and
former NCI director participate in a session.
And then all of a sudden, things started turning on Capitol Hill.
Republicans said, and compliment Senate Appropriations
Chair Susan Collins for doing this, in her very first hearing,
she said, "We need a hearing about NIH and what's happening, and we have
to stop this," and everything. So we applauded that.
It was a bipartisan congressional hearing about the importance of NIH funding.
As Roy, Dr. Herbst, alluded to, we partner with
AACI, the Association of American Cancer Institutes.
We had the largest Hill day we've ever had.
Cancer center directors from all over the country
participating in that event last year, making the case for NIH
funding.
AACR commissioned a poll with Republican pollsters and Democratic
pollsters to find out the general public support for medical research.
We found that 89% of the people said
medical research needs to be a
priority for this nation, for lawmakers.
They need to support medical research.
This poll was actually incorporated into our
annual AACR Cancer Progress Report.
The 15th edition was released this past September, and that
report is designed to inspire policymakers and the
general public to support cancer research.
The poll information also included something that was interesting.
90% of the respondents said that they would be more likely to vote
for a member of Congress if they are in support of medical
research, cancer research. 90% of the people would be willing
to vote against that member of Congress if they weren't going to support medical
research and cancer research. You can imagine that kind of information
we will take to Capitol Hill and show our policymakers, "Hey,
get behind this issue. This is important to your voters."
We have been for 14 years now,
AACR has been coordinating a Rally for Medical Research Hill Day.
We bring together 400 organizations and have a Hill
Day in September. We usually do this jointly with our release
with the Cancer Progress Report, but this is focused on all of NIH, all disease
areas. So the day before the Rally for Medical Research
Hill Day, we actually paid for a two-page ad in The Wall Street
Journal with all the organizations that declare their support for
medical research. This information goes directly to our lawmakers on Capitol Hill
to make a difference. We had a great, the largest ever, Rally for Medical
Research Hill Day. It's amazing because of the consequences people felt, they
needed to get involved, engaged, and participated in that rally in
Washington, DC, to meet with their members of Congress.
And what happened? So of course, we went through continuing resolutions.
We went through a government shutdown.
But eventually, in February,
NIH received its appropriation for FY 2026,
which was a nearly $500 million increase,
much better than the $20 billion increase that had
been proposed by the president. So, a major increase.
NCI received a $128 million increase.
And Congress pushed back on some of the
indirect costs that they wanted to cap at institutions. They pushed back on that.
They pushed back on the multi-year funding, which we saw, multi-year
funding resulted in nearly 500 less grants, or 400
grants less being funded by NCI
in FY 2025. So that's a concerning aspect,
multi-year funding. Because of that, the
180 fellows of the AACR Academy put together a statement of
support to Congress, an appreciation for their
efforts. It went to every single member of Congress, but focused on the leaders in
the Appropriations Committee. And if you were at the opening ceremony this morning,
Chair Susan Collins was awarded the AACR Public Service Award for
this year. At the end of that ceremony, there was placards,
"Thank you, Congress." I just saw a picture that was in
Stat, which is a major publication that's in Washington, DC,
with a picture of everyone in the crowd holding up those placards,
"Thank you, Congress," which we will be sending to every office on
Capitol Hill.
What has the President done? A couple of weeks ago,
proposed another budget cut for NIH.
His budget
proposal for FY 2027 would cut NIH by $6
billion overall. And
AACR immediately came out and said, "Reject
this budget, Congress, again. Go to work, and let's provide a robust
increase for NIH funding." So the same day we released that statement.
We've already held an AACR Early Career Hill Day.
That was our 10th annual to try to start the process, the advocacy
process on Capitol Hill, to generate support for this FY
2027 process. And these are the activities that
are planned here over the next few months with our
joint Hill Day with AACI. We're actually releasing a AACR Cancer
Disparities Progress Report, our fourth edition of that on June
24th. The AACR Cancer Progress Report in September.
Again, the 14th annual Rally for Medical Research, and our
Rally on the Road initiative, where we're going out to states and districts.
So that is my presentation. I'll turn it over to Nelly.
Thanks, John. We'll take questions at the panel for everyone.
All right. Wonderful. So thank you all for being here.
We're in a much better place than last year
And I don't know where to click either. Okay.
Well, I have no financial conflicts of interest, but I thought I would tell you a
little bit about the different roles that I have, because that will maybe
shape the questions that you may want to ask of me.
So first of all, I'm a cancer center director, and I'm a cancer center director
which has a pretty unusual area of service, which includes
five states, Utah, Montana, Wyoming, Idaho, and
Nevada. We serve 17% of the contiguous US
landmass, and especially a lot of those populations
where there has been discontent or concern, which is
rural and frontier communities. That means also
we pay a lot of attention to a unifying challenge, which is what we call
distance as a disparity. Now, of course, this cancer center also
has a lot of faculty, more than 300, more than 1,000
trainees, and we have about 20% of our
trainees and faculty being on visas or a green card or
something similar, and I personally have gone through a lot of those myself.
So with those five states come 10 senators.
So over the last year, my job has been really working with my
colleagues here and many others from our cancer centers to do
advocacy and partnering with my fellow directors,
with community members. We have here community advisory board
members that are patients from Wyoming coming with us to meet
with the senators. Your voices all mattered a whole
lot.
What's very important, and you know many cancer centers are
located on the East and West Coast.
What's very important is that we get away from this
adversarial partisan thinking towards a more
bipartisan thinking. Apologies.
I want to say that Jon Huntsman, who founded our cancer
center, with a large donation, actually
used to work for President Nixon, and he always went to
the Hill and said, "I'm neither Republican or Democrat.
I'm from the cancer party. I want to fight against cancer.
It affects everyone." And I think that has been a key message that has
resonated, as we just heard. So part of this committee,
if you have questions about the Association of American
Cancer Institutes, where I'm
now the president-elect, or if you have questions
about communication plans, we did a lot of work at Huntsman Cancer Institute, I'm
glad to have one of our members here in the audience, on how we can
engage our postdocs, our faculty, every single one on
communication that directly reaches people of the
community that honestly don't really know often what we do when we
talk about research.
So last but not least, I was also formerly a member of
the Board of Scientific Advisors to the National Cancer Institute, and
that was disbanded last year, and then a few months
later, I was called in to be the chair of the National Cancer
Advisory Board Ad Hoc Working Group on Extramural
Funding. And what that working group really does is to
advise the NCI on a number of matters regarding
scientific program policy, and also, most
importantly, we're the ones who are doing the first step in
approving these NOFOs, anything that comes out
to solicit specific research from the community.
This group was holding its inaugural meeting just in
February and had a second one since then, and if you're interested, all these
meetings are open to the public and live-streamed.
So those are my roles. Thank you for having me here, and looking forward to your
questions.
Okay. Thank you, Nelly. Next, John, you can either come to the podium or speak from
there, whatever you're more comfortable with.
I'm going to speak from here. We're all friends, and this should be a sort of
open conversation. But I want to make just a few framing comments at the beginning.
So, first I'm going to sort of describe some of the things that I'm seeing
in various roles that I have as a department chair, as an institute director with
around 230 faculty in our institute, and as someone who plays a role in a lot of
national foundations and other organizations.
There are a whole bunch of things that we should be considering.
I'm just going to touch on a couple key ones, but I want to preface it with just a
few kind of facts and figures to keep in mind.
First of all, drug development starts with academic science.
It always has. It probably always will.
There are statistics that we probably are all familiar with.
Between 2010, 2019, all but one of the
approximately 400 FDA-approved drugs had their point origin in academic
medical research.
Investment in NIH funding is the best return on
investment that we make with public funding, averaging about
2.5-fold return in economic activity just for the
things that we can link very directly and proximally to that money.
If you sort of expand the aperture just a little bit, you can come up with a number
that's more like tenfold if you take into account all of the activity that happens
in the private sector as well.
The other thing that I think is important and I think is often lost is that
we already subsidize NIH grant funding.
When grants come into our academic medical centers, yes, we
take overhead, or we should change the name of that to help us keep the lights on,
keep the plumbing working, make sure that there's security at the buildings.
But most of our academic medical institutions still lose
money on performing NIH research, and at least at many of the
large academic medical centers, we get a cost transfer from our health
system, or we find other ways of, in fact, subsidizing that work.
So an important point is that we're already in partnership with the NIH on how to
get academic medical science done.
So some of the things that have happened recently have been very troubling for me
as a department chair. The average time to a new faculty getting their first
R01 is really delayed.This is causing lots of problems for thinking
about promotion, thinking about what are the metrics that we can use to see whether
faculty are on track. In fact, we're very concerned
that things taking a long time to move from a score, from a study
section to an award, and not having a clear idea of what the
criteria are as it moves through, are making it very difficult to envision some
of our junior faculty getting promoted.
We have very difficult time hiring if we can't predict.
This is true in any industry, but it's especially true in academic medical science,
where we have to be predicting a long time ahead because there's such a
long delay in turnover of staff.
I'll just mention that we train about 8 to 10,000 PhDs in the US every
year. 70% of them end up in non-academic positions.
We are the source of the workforce for the biotech and the pharma industry,
and if we can't plan and predict how we can take on new
students or new post-docs into labs, we're going to lose that workforce very
quickly, and there's one obvious place where it's going to go.
It's not going to stay in the United States.
So I think we have to think very carefully about how we message the
risk of not making sure we have predictability in funding.
So we know that the pharma and biotech communities employ about two to three
million people in the US. That workforce is shrinking.
There's not jobs for a lot of the people we're training in academic
medical centers. And with this crunch on the other end that we can't
pay for or hire people,
we know what's going to happen. We're going to lose people from this career
path.
And I'll tell you, as you look at other industries, when these things happen,
you lose the best and the brightest people first because they have options to go
elsewhere. This is a really important message that we need to be
repeating over and over again, and it gets to a really important aspect of global
competitiveness. If we can't train the best and brightest people,
we are no longer going to be able to compete with China or other
areas overseas, and we're going to lose the ability to develop our own drugs.
So China now spends more on research and development than we do for the first
time in history. You can parse the numbers different ways, but the fact that you
can say that with at least one metric should be a shot across the bow.
In fact, I think we're late in the game of realizing that this is incredibly
important.
The original purpose of the NIH, and I wrote this down, this is from a report that
Vannevar Bush developed and delivered to President Truman.
The original purpose of the NIH in around 1945 was that federal
investment in basic scientific research was essential to the national
prosperity, health, and security.
Making sure that we can do medical research and develop our own drugs, our own
therapeutics, deliver them, and run clinical trials in the US is absolutely
essential for our competitiveness on a global stage.
We are losing that competitiveness very quickly.
We're losing that competitiveness in innovation and in pace of the science.
We're also losing it in the ability to do clinical trials effectively in the United
States. The FDA is very slow. We're seeing clinical trials
being done overseas, not just in China, but in Australia and other places,
where you can get a phase one clinical trial started in months, where in the
US it often takes a year to 18 months to get that
started. So NIH funding is one of the biggest
drivers of the US economy. It's not only important for
changing lives, treating cancer, but it's actually important as a national security
goal for the US. And I'll just mention at the end one last point.
I know we have the NCI director here, and it was great to hear his comments and
thoughts.
At our institution,
about 40% of the cancer research funding from the NIH comes
outside of the NCI. This is a problem for all of NIH, and so
when we see positive hints from the NCI, we see the White House
sort of talking about cancer research being important.
Don't forget those discoveries that came from very, very
diverse fields. And I'll just mention the last point about this.
We're all talking a lot about cancer vaccines and the importance of cancer
vaccines. The principles and the bedrock that we're going to have to stand on
to make cancer vaccines work better come from infectious disease.
We need to make sure that we're preserving great basic science across the spectrum
of biological research. That's what's going to make cancer research work long
term. So I'll stop there. Thanks, Roy.
Okay. A lot to think about, and we'll discuss it more in a few minutes.
Patty, the floor is yours.
Yeah, I'm also doing it from the bench without slides, but I'm going to
start with what I was going to kind of
end with, but I really think that research means a lot to patients.
What it means is what Jill said this morning. It gives us hope.
And it gives us hope that there's going to be new treatments and cures
possibly down the road. That's what research gives us.
And I think that one of the things, I'm a basic scientist by
trade, so I see the value in research
coming forward into clinical use and
to patients directly. But I think we have a problem communicating
that sometimes to everyone, to all the public, patients, community.
So I'm going to tell you what my rendition of
what are the benefits and consequences of
these research, not only the research going
down, but the delays in research are just as detrimental.
And I think even though the funding stayed the same, it seems like so much
changed, that there's so much uncertainty, nobody knows what's going on from
my perspective as not one on the inside type of
thing. But I think, I put things in buckets, so clinical
trials and research are my two buckets that I think of when I think of
NCI and NIH funding. NIAID is where we used to get all of our-- I
think it's really important as immunology comes forward for sure, and that's being
decimated.
But I see that patients know a lot about clinical trials and can definitely
see the benefits of clinical trials, right?
Because that's where the discoveries are made in the lab, and then they come
forward through clinical trials into clinical care and into patients.
And patients see that as really, this is how our drugs are getting to patients.
It's an opportunity for patients to get new drugs.
It's an opportunity for them to really do something that's going to help
future patients. And we can really see that.
And there's a huge difference between government-funded trials and
pharmaceutical-funded trials. And you can find whole lectures on
that, and I suggest that you look them up.
But there's a lot of difference there as far as the intent of the trial, the
information that comes out. The data sharing is essential, and that's a
tenet of the government-funded trials, not necessarily
pharmaceutical-funded trials. And the consequences are huge.
You heard about trials being stopped, right?
Patients are abandoned. They are just abandoned.
They can't continue with the trial.
They can't start the trial that they've been waiting to get on.
I've been on two trials. It's hard to get on trials.
And if you're told midway of eligibility that, "Oh, the trial's
stopped," that would be devastating, especially if that's a new treatment that
really might help you with your cancer.
So it really makes a huge difference, and it slows down the process, all of these
delays. And patients don't have patience. We don't have time.
A lot of patients don't have time. I know so many patients that have gone
on that trial that was just approved yesterday.
They went on it the next day. Right?
Because patients are waiting for these new drugs to come out, so slowing the
process is not an option. And then foundational or basic
research, that's where my home is, and that's where I really think that
the community and the patients and the public can really be on your side
if they really knew the value of that foundational research and
how that makes it. If you don't have foundational research, you have no drugs to
test in clinical trials.
That's where it comes from. And so I feel like that's where I think that
a lot of the information to
the public needs to come forward. And
also, the basic research is where you do all your training as
well. All of your trainees, I can see it.
I'm at Lineberger, and I met in different groups and stuff.
And I was asking around, "Hey, are you going to AACR?" "No, because I can
only do one meeting this year. I can only do two meetings this year." I have to
choose now what I do because there's so much
uncertainty going forward. Replacing people is not
happening. So there's a lot going on, and we're losing good labs,
and in those labs, we're losing good discoveries.
And in those good people, we're losing the new discoveries from the new people
coming forward. So I think, these delays and
cuts in funding, even though, okay, we made it out of last
year, but now we got to fight again because there's this lack of...
So as a patient, I think, what, they don't care about me?
They don't care that you're curing cancer?
They don't care that you're curing patients? Whatever the disease is.
NIH covers a lot of diseases. And how can you think that
that's actually right? So it's an emotional toll that it takes on
patients, too. So it's really diminishing our hope and diminishing
our hope and making cures and new treatments further away
for us as patients. So,
that's it.
Okay. Excellent. Thank you all. Everyone kept to time.
Now, we're in a town hall. So we have some microphones.
But I'm going to get us started, but make your way up as soon as you
want. And I'll start with one question.
Actually, you've come to the microphone. You can ask the first question, please.
Judy.
Hi. Thank you. So besides the funding
for the research being cut, I've spoken with
particularly academic researchers, where the rising
cost of the visa being brought up to
$100,000, where they're already
stretched to afford their staff. I'm
wondering if anyone is looking at that, if that's been changed.
I just Googled it to make sure it was still there.
But
what's resulting in that is that they can't afford to have
their students stay, and so they're going home, and
therefore the lab is pretty much done.
Does anybody know what's going on with that?
Why don't we have Nelly take the first crack?
I'll take a first crack. So first of all, I do want to say that
it's very important that you go to the town hall tomorrow of
Dr. Littai, the new NCI
director.Just to be clear,
this year, after a lot of bumps and changes,
we are expecting the same number of grants and money
disbursed as about in 2024. So last year was a big
slump, and it should come up this year despite still some forward
funding. So things are getting better.
I think it's very important to communicate to the labs.
There's major delays because of the government
shutdowns that happened. Many of you may have served on study sections
and know that they had to be delayed, but we're just starting
to see a lot of money getting disbursed.
One big challenge is still that the National Cancer Institute
has been decimated in its staff, and including the staff that is
supposed to give out the grants. And so that is
something that we can probably all still advocate for.
Now, your question about the $100,000 visa fee.
My understanding is that academic institutions are still exempt
from that at this point, and you should talk to your
international services office about it, and it's also
a difference if a student or somebody is already in the country and doesn't
have to leave. So, there's still some
uncertainty, but I was assured when I recently looked into hiring
somebody internationally, that it should not be a problem.
Now, should is should.
And so ideally, that person, if they may have done a
postdoc somewhere else, should get their visa before they leave the country.
So that is my minimal
suggestion on that front. Maybe others have more information,
but it's not as bad as it sounds because there was an understanding thanks
to everybody speaking up about foreign talent being
otherwise not able to come to us.
Anyone else? John, you have any experience with this?
Yeah, just very briefly. I think that that's right.
It's a sort of very narrow case
where that applies.
And so it's not as problematic systemically as
it sounded like initially.
But I did just talk to a colleague this morning at breakfast who said he just
paid $100,000 for a postdoc who's going to be coming
to him from Italy, actually.
Mm-hmm.
So I do think that there is a select set of cases where this is still
problematic, and it may vary by how each institution is addressing it.
But quantitatively, they seem to have narrowed the scope of where this is
a problem. That said, it's something we still need to push back on-
Mm-hmm
... because it's
a challenge of kind rather than number right now, and if that's going to
be the way we approach this problem, then we've missed the whole point
of trying to figure out ways to bring in the most talented people.
Mm-hmm.
Because I think what we're not really focusing on is that once
that lab loses these qualified people, the research is done.
Because to train new people, we're losing all the
talent, and
I don't know. I just think that we should be looking closer at,
to protect these people coming in and keep them here.
Yes. I think we all agree, so thank you. That's a great question.
I'm going to ask Patty now.
Public perception and from a patient point of view, and the public,
what's their feeling about all this, and how they're going to message this
to make a difference?
So I think one of the things is that there's a lot of jargon being
thrown around that people don't understand, and I'm
in the advocacy community, but I also have the research background, and
really nobody understands indirects.
So making indirects go to 15% sounds really, really good to most
people because they have no idea what the process was,
how it got to that point, things like that, the history behind it or
anything. And then other things that come up, "Oh, that sounds
okay." Like the forward funding. Nobody understands what the
impact might be. So I think there's a real
opportunity here for educating the public on some of these things
that are coming down. You hear these things because you just don't know what to
believe anymore. We have those discussions a lot, too.
You don't know what to believe. So if there's an honest source and an honest
broker that can really explain how this is going to really
impact patients, I think that would help a lot because what I hear is people
are confused.
Right. John, do you want to comment on indirect?
So indirect is the money that with a grant comes to
the center, and it varies based on each center's resources.
Is that something that we're finding, John Retzlaff?
Well, from an advocacy standpoint, we have really let
AAMC and AU, the institutions, take the lead on
that particular. They're the experts there because they're at the institutions that
really require that.
That's why maybe John went-
Over to John and Nelly in terms of specifics.
Yeah. I'm sure each of us can comment a little bit.
I think this is such a confusing topic, and I think this is a place where
scientists have not helped themselves.
We've made a lot of mistakes in how we communicate over a long
period of time, but it's become most acute in the last five years or so.
This is one of them. Indirects is a terrible word. I agree.
We shouldn't use it. You can think about science
like a giant shopping mall,
where individual scientists rent space from the shopping mall to
set up their business,
and everything about the shopping mall has to be
paid by their rent. And it's not exactly that indirects is
like rent, but you can think about it as the running cost for everything else
involved. And there are some proposals out there to sort of
reframe this concept
in terms of steady state running costs, things like electricity and
plumbing and rent depreciation on buildings and things like that,
than with other categories. If I'm running a research lab, I don't
want to run the books on how much money I have.
In fact, that would be a terrible idea, especially if you let me do it.
I will be over budget way more than I already am.
Several other things, you don't want me running HR.
I'll probably be in jail by the end of the week.
So there are these categories of things that we have to actually
subcontract outAnd it's very much like having space in a shopping
mall or in a business park where you can subcontract those things out.
That is the way we need to think about it.
And what we need to think about is we need to take away all of
those responsibilities from the scientists so the scientists can
do what we want them to do, which is make discoveries.
And that's the way we need to think about what that cost is that goes around
them to put them in an environment where science can happen.
Nelly?
I'll just add to it, the correct term is facilities and
administration, or F&A, which explains pretty clearly
it's facilities and administrations, it's our IRB,
it's our pre-award and post-award.
It's our human resources that we won't hire you for.
But,
there is a very clear process on that,
and we have, as you said, not done ourselves a favor.
We should say that it's not just been communication with the public, it's been
communication with our elected officials, where we had to
really start and really explain and delineate and
note how these processes work. And
likewise, there's other terms like forward funding, multi-year funding-
Yeah
... out-year funding-
It changes every time
... that all sound great and really are
detrimental. And so we've done a lot of work trying to figure out
how to communicate appropriately over the last year.
I think the bottom line is
we want a message that federal funding is going to allow us to
make progress in improving
health and saving lives. And there's a lot of components of that, but I think we
start losing the argument once we start going down this rabbit hole of all these
indirect costs and things like that.
Overall, federal funding is going to improve health for our nation and save
lives, and that's bottom line, why we are asking for robust, sustained, and
predictable funding increases on an annual basis for NIH and NCI.
Well said. A more simple message.
Yes.
Hi, my name is Carly. I'm a PhD student from UT
Health. Thank you for holding this session.
I think it's really important
and also interesting hearing
the work that you guys are doing, because as a PhD student, I don't always hear
this.
And I've directly felt the impacts of what's been going on.
I want to especially thank all of you guys for holding this, but especially Dr.
Wherry. Did I pronounce that correctly? Okay.
Because as a first generation PhD student,
I always looked at science as a stable career, and now,
kind of is it stable? A lot of students have been
affected by the grants being canceled.
My university had an IMSD grant that was canceled.
If I was an undergrad, I was a part of MARK and RISE and LSAMP.
So my question for you guys is, I heard that they might be kind of
bringing some of these back, but do you have any ideas or
suggestions for how to increase stability for these kinds of
programs to retain talent, so that from an administration to
administration, there's not so many ebbs and flows?
Because I know from my perspective, as a first generation PhD student,
if this had happened before I started grad school, I might have been
really thinking if I wanted to still
do this.
Who wants that one?
I can.
Nelly.
Want me to start?
Go ahead. I'll turn it...
Well, thank you for being here. I'm first generation as well.
So, we all
have noticed that the terms DEI, right, or EDI,
whichever way people have expressed it, have been really a
very challenging topic over the last year.
And that is where
grants have been canceled, and where especially training grants
are, from my perspective, probably not coming back through
the National Cancer Institute or NIH.
There are other funding agencies that are still very committed and
have less restrictions on that, for example, the American Cancer
Society. And so I think these programs will
continue. However, there has been also a concerted effort to really
say we want to provide health for all, health
equity for all, and a concerted effort to
really help our early career scientists and our
trainees. And for example, during the last NCAB working
group meeting, we passed a number of RFAs that
are for K99 ROO or K99,
and other T32
PARs. So those continue to be at the top of the
priority of the National Cancer Institute to continue
to reassure and grow the workforce.
So even though some specific programs may not exist, I think
there's really a deep commitment, including with early career
investigator pay lines that are significantly larger than for others, even though
the word pay line is not a word now anymore, it's called a success rate.
But the success rates are significantly larger if you're an early career
investigator. So I would encourage you to not give up at this point
and just see how this all shakes out.
I think there is a real commitment by Congress,
by the National Cancer Institute, by the NIH, and by many, many others.
AACR has done a tremendous job, and maybe John wants to chime in
here, American Cancer Society and other funders who recognize
how important it is to provide a stable
future for our talent today.
Yeah, that's great. John, do you want to comment on it?
The board has some new initiatives under Lillian.
Yeah, it was just announced this morning, so Trailblazer grants and
everything, and please look on our website because I know we're trying to help in
terms of bridge funding and new grants opportunities and everything to
try to assist in some way. There's no question
organizations are just not going to be able to take the place of the federal
government when it comes to providing support overall.
But we can help in certain ways, and many organizations are stepping up to the
plate at this point to do that.
John Wherry
Yeah. So again, thanks for being here, and thanks for caring about this topic.
It's really encouraging to see that. Just three quick comments.
So one, to echo Nelly's comment, stick with it.
Just because
it's getting harder, doesn't mean it's not the right thing for us to do.
I think we all need to view it that way, that this is too
important to let these kind of things veer us off path.
The second thing, to echo John's comments, there are organizations that are
stepping into this space. Now, the collection of organizations,
AACR, and some foundations will not make up the entire federal government.
But there's two reasons that it's important to recognize that that's there.
One, we can push for more of that. AACR is stepping up to do this.
And when we do that, the messaging associated with it brings
further spotlight to this gap and this problem.
So I would
encourage everyone to push for those things.
We know where some gaps in the system are, but we may not be focusing on some other
gaps that we need to recognize, including the ones that you mentioned.
The last thing I'll say is,
with changing political landscapes on certain topics like DEI,
early career, first in research kinds of things,
the words may change. But one of the things I am most encouraged about, both at my
institution,
a- and nationally,
is the real commitment of scientists to just do the right
thing.
Call it whatever you want,
but let's just do the right thing. We need diversity in science.
We need diversity in science, and research, and clinical trials in all
ways of using that word, not just because it's the right thing to do, but
frankly, makes science better. And I'm really encouraged to see that
thread coming through every place we go talk about this.
We change the names, call it whatever you want,
but we need to continue to do that. So I would really push your message as you
talk to people about this.
Thank you. That was really encouraging to hear.
Great. Yes, please, Jonathan.
Thanks, Roy. Jonathan Potter from Pfizer.
As a former communicator and now somebody who works in patient advocacy, I have a
question for Patty. So I fully agree
that there's a lot of misinformation, mistrust out there, and there
is a need for that trusted broker to convey what's real and what's going to be
impactful for patients. I'm wondering, at Lineberger, are there
successful strategies that you and the community outreach team have done
to really amplify that public education,
demystify the foundational research process, how that
contributes to tomorrow's cancer breakthroughs that everyone can learn from?
Yeah. We haven't really done anything yet, but I think that all of the
cancer centers are now challenged to do more as far
as getting research out to the community, and we just started a
project that we haven't launched yet.
It's still in the planning stages, where we're going to take current
publications that just came out and make it very lay
friendly and more an Instagram, multiple thing that we can
push out to the community that's a little bit different than what we do in the
news. We do a lot in our newsfeed and things like that.
But we really want to see if we can touch the people that aren't being touched
right now, and really don't know what a cancer center does, or what
cancer research is, and what it might find out for you, and how it
helps patients. So it's really just how will this help patients is basically the
bottom line. But I think there's a real effort to try to do more
of that,
and communicate more in different ways.
It's not going to be just one thing that's going to do it.
It's going to do a lot, and I work a lot with the researchers,
trying to kind of bridge that. But I think there needs to be a lot
more at all of the cancer centers, and I think it is
through the community outreach and engagement offices at the cancer centers
where all of that is happening.
Absolutely. Nelly, your thoughts?
I hate to jump in all the time, but this is probably my
favorite topic. I think we worked with our communications team last year
to start a special communications plan that really
addressed, I think, some of the needs and gaps that we saw.
And so, that engaged everybody. We had post-docs doing a lot of
videos that explained their why, that sit there and talk in lay
terms why they care about their research, why they're here.
We invited a lot of patients to come to our labs.
They were social media influencers and started to talk about it.
We worked with the Utah Mammoth, the hockey team, in case you
know that. And a lot of where people get their
information now from is through social media.
Mm-hmm.
A lot of our patients were speaking in their own words.
I still remember a farmer from Idaho who was
talking very plain language about why he came to Huntsman, and he said, "I saw
all these young people sitting there with cancer, and I just feel we need more
research to help them." That was so meaningful, and so I
think every single one of us cancer centers, together with
AACR and AACI, has really stepped up, and the
NCI as well. You saw the videos this morning.
But every single one of you in the room here can make a difference as well, and
we're happy to share. I think we've been really trying
to communicate that amongst the organizations on communicators, but
we feel like it's really made a difference, and also has been meaningful for the
community of researchers to be able to speak up in some way.
Yeah, in our program, we're going with the young researchers, and we send them a
thing. "So what was your research about?
Do you have a quote that you want us to use?" We really engage them in the process-
Mm-hmm
... so that they can tell their story to the public and stuff.
And we always have a lot of community and patients coming
in and volunteering for different things within the research realm
of the thing. Because it's a bidirectional learning.
The patients and communities need to learn about the research, and the only way
they can do it is really be engaged, and vice versa, letting our
researchers be exposed to more patients and community members.
It's a process, but it's really worth it to put the effort in.
Yeah. Those personal stories are so important on Capitol Hill.
When we go on our Rally Hill day and the Hill days,
we tell everyone, "You have to tell your story." The members of Congress, the
staff, that's what resonates with them. That's what moves the needle.
Right. Then the other thing the AACR has done recently is Early Career Hill Day.
So you bring associate members and students to the Capitol
Hill. And I led that one year. I'll tell you, it's amazing because
the people that are in their PhD years going to the
offices of their states and talking and telling about
what they're doing and how their work is at risk.
And that also trains them so that they can be on these panels in 10 years or five
years. So these are all great questions. Yes, please.
Yeah. Thank you so much. My name is Diego Pedrosa.
I'm from Baylor College of Medicine. So I have two questions.
So the first one is,
as John was mentioning earlier,
so as somebody who's going to start their own lab here in the fall,
how are we supposed to be encouraged to apply?
How are we going to fill in the gap of R01
grants? I know you don't want to talk about indirect costs, but places like
Baylor, who rely on indirect costs to survive,
and they want you to bring in the indirect costs to sustain the lab and
to turn on the lights in the place and to keep your lab going.
How are we going to basically supplement that?
Is it going to be through foundation grants?
How are we going to make up that dividend? So that's my first question.
And then my second question is basically, as
somebody who's lucky enough to have gotten a K99, and then has gotten
unlucky enough to have it terminated, and then gotten lucky enough to get it
back because we sued them. So I'm just
wondering, since the NCI director's somewhere here, who's going to
tell him to tell the NIH director, because
I see the news, and this guy goes on these conservative
journals and says that he's cured DEI.
This is for Patty. As a DEI person here, we
published a paper and Insight Pharmaceutical Company gave $1
million, and we're now running a full-blown clinical trial.
This is directly to poor patients.
So, I'm getting really tired of this. Obviously, we're not going to stop.
Like John mentioned, I think it's important to keep going.
But, it's getting really tiresome.
So I would like for somebody to tell the NCI director to tell the
NIH director that, "Hey, man, it's not that simple."
Tomorrow afternoon, you'll have your opportunity.
Yeah.
If you can, I would like to-
He'll be conducting a fireside chat. There won't be a fire necessarily.
Maybe there'll be a fire somewhere, but no. It's going to be a big room.
Hopefully, those questions will be posed to him.
And he has been talking about, we've heard him
speak many times. He came to the ACR board meeting and everything, and he
has talked about how there will be more money going out in
FY 2026 for extramural research than ever before in the
history of NIH and NCI.
We need data, though. And all of you, if you're
applying for grants, and all of a sudden there are no pay lines,
so there's a lot of uncertainty out there because of that and everything.
But if you're not getting funded and it's different than it's been in the past,
we need to know, because that's the kind of information that we can take to Capitol
Hill that will help us with that data to possibly
get people to take some action on things, and for us to go
to the administration. I'll give you an example.
Just this past week,
OMB Director Voigt was on Capitol Hill and told
the members of Congress that
he would not guarantee that they're going to allow the money that
Congress appropriated to NIH will be spent.
And
he's saying that OMB is going to make sure that money is spent wisely.
Congress has appropriated the dollars to NIH. NIH needs to spend those dollars.
If OMB is trying to put a roadblock in there, there's a big problem, and that's
when Congress is going to have to assert its authority like it did last year.
Senator Britt, Republican from Alabama, had 12 other Republican
senators send a letter to OMB because of the slow spend.
They were getting close to the end of the fiscal year. NIH had a lot of money.
There was concern that if they didn't spend the money by September 30th, it was
going to go back to the Treasury Department.
These Republicans said, "Spend the money." And they got Dr.
Bhattacharya, the NIH director, to assure that that would happen.
And he assured everybody in Congress this past week that they would be spending the
dollars. But you can just see what's happening.
It's Whac-A-Mole. We are fighting all kinds of different angles,
but we need data, and if you can provide that kind of information to us, that
will be very helpful. Through your organization, and
we work with all the government affairs
officials from all the different institutes, organizations, and things, and we all
collectively are always talking.
So that's a good answer to your second question.
What was the first?
And keep your advocacy. I wrote it down.
The first question was about who's going to pay the indirects,
because there are those costs. One way, I guess, would just be to make the grants
more. But how are you doing with this at Penn?
Yeah. So it's a really important question.
I advise all of my junior faculty to think about your
lab funding like your retirement account.
You have to diversify. Now,
maybe I shouldn't say this
publicly in case my bosses are listening, but indirects are not your
responsibility. F&A is not your responsibility to worry about.
Let your department chair worry about what that blend looks like.
You might get some pressure, and that's fair at a certain point.
Early on in your career, my advice to my junior faculty is
to just fuel the science. So those foundation
grants that pay 20% instead of whatever it is, 70%
They're still funding your lab, and without that funding, you're
not going to have the preliminary data to get the
second R01. And so I think it's much more important in the first couple of
years to make sure you're diversifying, apply for foundation grants.
There are a large number of programs for people exactly at your career stage.
Use university pilot grants to bridge the gap across things.
Look to the private sector, Incyte or other companies, to form
relationships that are long-term, so it's not just a one and done.
I think it's really important to have a diverse portfolio that buffers you to some
extent from these things that are happening.
That's why I'm advising everybody,
let the department chairs and cancer center directors worry about the overall
blend at some point.
Annel, you have a thought on this, too, I think.
I have a question. What is the only grant that doesn't
get funded? Audience.
The one you don't submit.
So last year, our cancer center submitted more grants than ever
before in its history, and they're all in the pipeline.
And at the same time, talking about diversifying, think outside the box.
There's the Department of Defense.
It has significant amount of fundings.
There's ARPA-H, great ideas. A lot is
going into space now, engineering.
Are there any research questions related in radiation
oncology or other areas that are relevant to space?
So think outside the box. Look at what are the NIH priorities,
what are the NCI priorities, what are the White House priorities.
You might be surprised how much of it is actually relevant to cancer and
maybe really exciting transdisciplinary research.
I love that line about the grant that you don't submit. I'm going to use that.
Yeah.
Okay, next question.
Hi. First of all, thank you for all your efforts over the past one and a
half years. I can only imagine how quickly everyone came together
once the news about the new budget came out.
But,
focusing on more long-term, how do you think
we and ACR as an organization can push the right buttons
to get a more cultural shift to where
we can see NIH budget increases as the norm,
or at least we don't have to worry about us being
on the chopping block as often?
So John Retzlaff's seen this for many years. You saw the doubling way back?
Yes.
Give us a little perspective on how this works.
Yeah. I was actually on Capitol Hill in both the Senate and House Appropriations
during the five years that NIH was being doubled.
We had some champions, Arlen Specter and Tom Harkin in the
Senate, and John Edward Porter in the House,
Rosa DeLauro, making sure that happened.
So then after the doubling,
we went into a ten-year
flat funding. And when you talk about flat funding, you're talking about reduced
overall funding because you're not taking into account inflation.
And actually, 14 years ago at the ACR annual meeting,
the ACR board of directors said something dramatic needed to be done
because we had not grown for 10 years of flat funding.
And we're kind of in that spot now. It's been two years of flat funding, pretty
much. And the dramatic thing we did was we had a rally for
medical research outside of the annual meeting when it was held in Washington, DC,
and brought policymakers there. And we had champions that we
were really trying to push forward.
Roy Blunt, Tom Cole,
Patty Murray. They all joined together and said there needs to be robust funding
for NIH and everything. And that's why we've continued the Rally for Medical
Research Hill Day. And the entire community, 400 organizations, have been
working to ensure that robust funding.
So we've worked together, and I think now is the
time to have that same kind of concerted effort to
point out that we've had a few years of no growth,
and the opportunities have not stopped. The opportunities have exploded.
And if we
have less money to do that,
it's a huge concern. And there's so many reasons why we do this.
It's to improve health, save lives.
But it's also, there's economic benefits to this funding that you don't see
in any other kind of spending that's going on.
International competitiveness, even with this administration.
That's something that can resonate with them.
Just in terms of ensuring that the United States does
maintain a lead in this area. We want to work with the entire
world. There's no question about this on things.
But we don't want to all of a sudden find everyone else taking the
lead because they're making it a priority.
It needs to continue to be a priority here.
So we'll just continue that effort and hopefully get on another growth.
We're not advocating for doubling anymore, but we're advocating for robust
increases. 5% increase above inflation
would really put medical research on a
great path.
Agree. Patty?
Yeah, and I think it is. What is the mindset now that has changed so much that
it's really detrimental? And I think in the old days, if it was flat
funding, it was like, "Oh, no, we need more." Right?
And that was the fight. We wanted to get more.
Now it's like, "Oh my God, they want to cut 40%.
Oh my God, they want to cut 20%. How can we get up to flat funding?" Right?
Right.
This is different. So it's a different thing that we have to do.
So how can we change that mindset, either on the Hill or
everywhere, that this is just not acceptable, and this can't
happen every year. It's emotionally draining for everyone,
I think.
What about showing the government we're leveraging the funding with other sources?
So John, where do these Trailblazer Awards come from? Where's that money?
And what about industry alliances and things like that?
Is that something to-
Well, actually, it was a gift from Pfizer, the Trailblazer
grants, that allowed NIH to have those dollars to be able to
provide funding. And so leveraging industry support is
extremely important, and industry has stepped up to the table on many
occasions here.
There's private foundations that are
really doing their part in many ways and everything, and just getting
the entire general public to understand the importance of medical research.
People want to do things that make a difference, and this is one area that they can
really get behind.
Right. Nelly, we just had a meeting where they talked about public-private
partnerships. Is that something that you're trying to implement at your center?
Yeah, absolutely. I have to say that, for our colleagues
in pharma industry, it's been a little bit of a rocky ride themselves,
I would say. So the disruptions that are happening are just
starting to subside, and I think everybody realizes the
benefit, as I think you talked about, the workforce that
needs to be there. Or last year, I talked to a friend of
mine, who was kind of discouraging.
He was in industry, and he said, "Well, it's kind of great for us because all these
good people come to us." I'm like, "What?"
But that is a temporary effect, and it will certainly not be
the same. And now we are so grateful for the partnership with
many industry partners who are coming also to cancer centers and say,
"What can we do?" And some of them actually partner with us on community
outreach and engagement and on bringing clinical trials to
rural communities, something that we care a lot about.
And that is so important because we cannot have
a divide across any groups with respect
to getting those newest discoveries and best new
drugs and being cured by them. The biggest challenge that we
still have in the United States is that
mortality after an identical diagnosis is much
worse if you live in a rural community.
And so we need to recognize that. It's also something that resonates with
our elected officials as something that we want to
launch. And when I talk about DEI, that is one
component where I say this is health for all.
It's rural, it's other underserved communities where we really have to make a
difference together.
I think John?
Yeah, I just wanted to sort of
pull a thread a little bit more in the comment that you made, because I think
there's something more pervasive and something that I think we should
discuss, that I worry a lot about. And that is, to make a
long-term change so that there's more stability in the system,
I think we need to recognize that we've lost trust, that a
large part of this country doesn't trust science or frankly,
scientists. We could argue, and it may be an important
different discussion about who's responsible for that loss of trust, and it may be
intentional in ways. But the fact is, we've lost the trust of a lot
of the country.
So how do we get that back? When you ask across party
lines, "Do you support cancer research?" The answer's always yes.
Then you say, "Well, we're doing work in mice or fruit flies." They're
like, "Why would you do that?"
We're
just not talking on the same wavelength about things, and we have to figure out
ways to communicate across these big
divides in the way we speak about science and
research.
Mm-hmm.
And we're not very good at that as a community.
Scientists really distance ourselves from people who don't have a
science background, and so we have to do better. How do we do that?
There are a whole bunch of ways. That's another two hours of conversation.
But I think we have to recognize that that's a core problem that we have to face
somehow.
Mm-hmm.
It's the only way we're going to get to a point where there's at least some more
stability in this.
Great. We're having a great discussion.
I actually just noticed some online questions, too, so I'll get to those in a
minute. But let's take the people who are up at the microphone. Yes, please.
Hi, my name's Alex.
I'm a postdoc here at UCSD.
And I had a question about the plan for
advocacy going forward. So I appreciated hearing the summary
about how the budget was restored or protected
last year. It sounds like it's definitely a blueprint to keep using.
Probably other organizations can use, too.
But, as someone who's involved in our union of postdocs and project scientists on
our campus, we're still seeing layoff notices every week.
Orientation sessions are half the size they used to be, so the workforce is
definitely still shrinking. And that's not a
function of the budget, because obviously that was a success that ACR had.
It's now coming from these bad faith,
executive actions. I'm glad you mentioned OMB a minute ago.
In terms of staffing at NIH, in terms of slow walking funding, in terms of its
multi-year funding. And I definitely hear the difficulty that was
talked about a couple of minutes ago about, it's hard enough to message about
funding to the public. How do we message about all this crazy percentages and
things like that? But at least in terms of advocacy to Congress for this next
cycle, is there a plan to
focus on putting more statutory guardrails here that we didn't need in the past?
But there's a different kind of thinking and ideology in the
executive branch right now.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. So absolutely. I mean,
multi-year funding in FY 2025 resulted in
400 less grants that NIH was able to fund than the
previous year. And across NIH, it was more than 5,000.
So that's why you're seeing what you're seeing and everything.
Fortunately, there was a backstop that Congress put forward for going forward for
FY 2026 that is not allowing NIH to do any more
multi-year funding than they did in FY 2025.
And that's where Dr. Litaiz has said that
multi-year funding shouldn't be that much of an issue here in
FY 2026 as they're distributing the dollars and everything.
But that's where the advocacy community, ACR, and everyone else is working and
looking at the data and going to
make people accountable here and making sure that that is true.
So we're spending a lot of time on not just the
fact that we're trying to inspire people to support overall funding,
but we're getting into the weeds, so to speak, in terms of multi-year funding and
the slow spend. AAMC has a wonderful
report that just came out. They're tracking it by month, and last
month, it showed that we are 67% behind NIH.
It's 67% behind in terms of its spending than
they have been for the, if you look back five previous years before
FY 2025. Now-Dr. Lattai will say that
is, and others at NIH will say that's because there was a government shutdown,
that the bill was signed in February, so it was late, that kind of thing.
Maybe their employees are slow. But we are watching that like a
hawk. That report is coming out every week in terms of this.
And if we don't start seeing it ratchet up, that's when we're talking to members of
Congress, and that's where they'll put letters to OMB and to NIH saying,
"Get these dollars up," and everything.
So,
there's a lot of different components here that we are constantly
watching. There's no longer notices of funding opportunities that institutes
can go out to let the community know where
they could have specialized areas that are important to the
institutes and everything. But Dr.
Lattai said he's going to have some targeted areas that he can
communicate to the community about what's important and everything.
So hopefully I've answered some of the question, but I think there's a lot
more we need to do.
And I just want to add, I think out of every crisis comes something
positive. Out of COVID, we learned how to do Zoom calls,
right?
I don't know.
But what has come out of the last year is a true alliance
of all the cancer advocacy, whether it's AACR or
AACI or ATSCAN or patient advocates and
cancer centers, and everybody standing together and
finding their voice and starting to monitor things.
So I think that we are in a much better place now.
Great point. Yeah.
Yes, please.
Hi.
I was hoping we could maybe talk a little bit about stagnant
funding for Medicare, Medicaid, and how that is
impacting not just patients'
ability to participate or get the care they needed,
but also how it affects cancer research.
So, for example,
I
used to work with Nali, but now I'm in Oregon at the Providence Cancer Institute
of Oregon. And Providence is a
seven-state nonprofit healthcare system.
And in Oregon,
70% of their patients are
Medicare or Medicaid.
Hospitals around the country are hemorrhaging
money on
in-hospital patient care, particularly Medicare and Medicaid,
which pays a fraction on the dollar of the cost of
caring for an inpatient
stay. And so the revenue
that
nonprofits were generating who are caring for a lot of these really
underfunded or unfunded patients, the
clinical revenue
has dropped. And so how does that impact
cancer research? In the obvious ways, that includes indirect
funding. So our cancer institute
now has been told we
have less support for
facilities and administration. We have less support from our hospital
system, which is nonprofit and is hemorrhaging money.
So,
I'm wondering what discussions are going on and advocacy are going
on for while we're trying to advocate for
NCI research funding,
how does that dovetail with advocacy for Medicare,
Medicaid funding as well?
John, you want to start with that?
So
I'll tie this in with the ACR fourth edition of the Cancer Disparities
Progress Report that we'll be releasing.
Actually, we have a meeting on Tuesday with the steering committee to start talking
about what's going to be in that report.
And some of the things we want to do is talk about rural
populations. We want every person in this country to
have access to the latest and best treatments and everything.
And I guess what I would say is we should have a
page in that report on this issue that you're bringing up.
So let's talk in the next 24 hours so that we can put it
before the steering committee and make sure that this
kind of issue, because it is extremely important.
You're talking about income disparities,
rural disparities on different things, and Medicare,
Medicaid, that ties into this. So I think that's the kind of thing that
we can do from an educational standpoint.
We have these reports that we take to Capitol Hill, and then we drill down on the
different issues, and we will have a congressional briefing.
We'll take those issues and drill down even further, and then there'd be an
opportunity to work with a member of Congress who all of a sudden will come up with
maybe, "Hey, what kind of legislation is needed to move things forward?" Sometimes
all of this can take a lot of time in terms of getting an idea through
to a law and everything. But,
just bringing it up today helps from the standpoint of, it's the kind of thing that
we can start that process through the educational report.
Anyone else want to comment on that?
It's certainly an issue for clinical trials, right, Nelly?
Yeah, but I think you have your online questions. There's two more.
Yeah. We have, uh-
I think John is in charge here.
Okay. We got John. We got the committees.
I'll ask an online question. Is there any information on how advisory councils will
decide on grant funding? So I guess the pay lines and how's
that going to work?
All right. Well,
this is not something the advisory councils do, and I think
maybe we'll talk a little bit about this point of we don't have a pay line, and
what are the criteria, and so why is there a success rate?
So this has actually changed back and forth, we
realized through the history of the NCI.
The concept of a clear pay line
has been much more advocated over the past years.
And it has its pluses and minuses because it can mean that
you have lessLess ability to fund
high-risk science. I think many of you have noticed that
if you propose something that's innovative, where you don't have the super strong
preliminary data, it has a harder time.
Sometimes you have to propose a grant that's already half
done in order to make that pay line.
And I think there are some really positive thinking behind it
for program staff to be able to engage with
grantees and their applications to understand, is this new
and innovative? Did maybe one reviewer just have a problem here that was
not really justified? And have that dialogue and make a
decision also based on when they say, "Oh, there are already four grants
on ovarian cancer that are running and doing the same thing.
Even though it is ranked very highly, I'm sorry, but I'm going to fund pancreatic
cancer this time." So it's a little bit of a back and forth, and
I think we should see how this plays out with the success
rate. But there is really some positive about it as well.
Great. Thanks. Let's keep moving on so we can get all the questions.
We're in the last 10 minutes. Yes.
Thank you guys so much for your insights so far. Really appreciate it.
And you guys have kind of alluded to some of these points, and I know a really
big focal point has been kind of just the communication barriers and how the fact
that the public's speaking a different language than researchers, policy makers are
speaking a different language than researchers.
And I'm just kind of thinking about the general structure of it and the Hill days,
and the Appropriations Committee is usually meeting
year-round, and it seems like kind of a lot to just kind of really
establish, okay, this is why our work is important, and here's why you need to
fund it, on one or two days per year, maybe.
So I'm just kind of curious, how do you guys think we can proactively include
policymakers in on the conversations and the grants we're proposing, and kind
of instead of having it be disparate entities, have it actually be a
collaborative discussion on the front end?
Hmm.
Well, I think one thing is talk to your institution and your cancer
center.
We have many times,
elected officials come visit. We have them tour, we have them meet
with junior investigators, and trainees.
And so that's one thing. But also keep in mind, you're a citizen.
You're welcome to make a phone call anytime.
Everybody can as a citizen. So just make sure if you do that, that
you're not saying you're representing the institution.
You're saying you're calling as a private citizen. This is your story.
You'll be surprised how many times people listen to specifically phone calls.
Any other comments?
Why don't we take
your question, then I have another online question.
Okay. So I'll preface my question with, there may or may not be clarity on this
yet, but my question is, what is the impact
or not impact of this MAHA Institute to the
global medical and research community, if the panel is willing or
can comment on this, the M-A-H-A Institute.
Make America Healthy Again.
I'll take a first crack at this. First of all, when your question starts, there may
not be clarity on this, about this
administration, the answer is we don't know.
So,
it's not clear, but I think
for some of this stuff, we shouldn't just react.
There are aspects of saying, we need to
look at overall health differently that we should embrace.
I know we don't like the messenger a lot of times, but the message
may have some utility to it. Now, my opinion, our
job is, is to make sure that the solutions
are fact-based, evidence-based, rigorous science.
But healthy foods?
Microplastics and microparticles?
Yeah, we should be looking at these things.
So I think we should maybe try to meet this somewhere.
I guess if I could be a little more specific with it, are there going to be
grant funding mechanisms in here? Is there any clarity on any of this?
That I don't know that there is any clarity, but...
Well, keep in mind there will be far fewer program announcements,
but what every grant should do is write about how it aligns
with NIH priorities, with HHS priorities.
So you can certainly put that in your grant application under the umbrella
funding mechanism.
Great. We have an online question asking, "Should pharma have a
collaborative panel to discuss public education instead of just drug
ads that talk about side effects?" So I guess someone's asking, how
can we get pharma to be more involved in public education?
I don't know if I'm the right person to take that, but I think they do some of
this, but it's a great suggestion.
I think you'd find a lot of receptivity from folks in pharma to
partner on better communication. I think it's a great idea.
I think there is some of this that happens.
But any way that we can get the message out, I think it benefits the entire
ecosystem.
I think it speaks just to collaboration.
I think sometimes pharma does do a good job in some things,
because if I'm thinking about a topic that I want to teach
advocates or patients about, I can go to some pharma sites and find
brochures and different things, but they all have a marketing edge to them, so
I'll never use them. But they do have
good communications and good things about the drugs that they sell.
They do a lot in that area, and the diagnostic companies do the
same thing. But they all have that a little bit marketing edge to them.
But they do a good job of communicating some of these complex
terms to the public, actually.
If we're going to make a difference, it's going to take a large village, and we
need everyone working together on this, no question about it, so...
Yeah, and I'll just comment. We do need better sources of education.
If you go online to look up a cancer, who knows what you'll
find. It's not accurate. So there does need to be some sort of collaborative,
in my opinion, that produces materials for patients to help them navigate, because
it's hard even for any of us who are in the field to know what to do.
Okay, we only have five minutes, and we have three people at the microphone, so
we're going to have quick questions, quick answers. Yes, please.
Okay. Just back to the education part.
I think that most people don't realize that cancer funding
doesn't only come from NIH and NCI, but from the
CDMRP program, which is in the defense
budget. And the reason it was put there was because they
felt that the defense budget would always be approved.
But now, with the war going on, is there any concern that some of that
money will be taken?
No. The budget for DoD has been quite strong this year.
And you can look it up. And it depends on which kind of cancer,
but overall, it's a stable funding source.
But to your point about the
funding. So NCI, the president proposed flat funding for
NCI in FY 2027 for NCI. NIH,
all the other institutes, 12% cut.
As John said, 40% of the dollars that are coming to
Penn are from across all of NIH. So that's why ACR came
out completely against the budget proposal.
Congress, it does not fly to all of a sudden say, "Okay, we're going to protect one
institute, and we're going to decimate the rest of NIH." We're in
it together with the entire advocacy community to
ensure growth overall for NIH. And special programs, if it
happens for cancer research, which there's a rationale for,
absolutely, to get an extra bump up.
Okay. Quick question.
So it strikes me that there's an ongoing battle for the American
mind.
And no clearer an example is there in the incredible
success of the COVID vaccines that came from
basic biomedical research, but which have been flipped
on us as a way of beating down science
and scientists.
And I think that we need to do a better job, as
a
community, fighting back against
misinformation, because we are fighting a fair
battle,
but the people on the other side of the argument are not.
And they're fighting with misinformation and straight out lies.
And I think that ACR and our institutions need
to fight that battle more aggressively. I think we're too passive.
Mm-hmm.
Anyone disagree?
I agree.
We all agree.
Okay.
Agree.
Good. Thank you. And the final question.
Hi, I'm Carmen Guerra from the University of Pennsylvania.
I have a suggestion, a small one, but it may have
some impact, which is about clinical trials. And thank you.
You all spoke about clinical trials.
Patty, you spoke very eloquently about what they mean to patients.
When all of this was happening,
I was getting constantly asked about, can you find the
patients whose clinical trial was disrupted, and now they
can't access treatment. I learned that there is no
system for finding those clinical trials that
were disrupted by all of these funding cuts and
funding freezes. And I wonder if we could just change
clinicaltrials.gov to make it a mandatory field
that your NIH grant should be listed on that.
There is a field for funding, but it's conditional.
And so if we could make the data more transparent, it
would be easy to find all those clinical trials that are disrupted, the numbers of
patients who no longer will access their therapy.
And I think that would be also, you could make a positive story
like, "The NIH has funded all these trials, and all these patients were impacted,
and look at the cure." So small suggestion, but maybe something that can help
us as we tell our story.
I like it. Any comments?
That would've been-
Good idea.
... extremely helpful to have that. No question.
Okay. Well, that-
We did have an individual that we highlighted in the cancer progress report,
whose
trial was canceled. It was detrimental to his
care and everything. It was because there were experts at NIH that were laid
off in the Cancer Clinical Center.
But to your point, we need that data.
Okay. Well, thanks again to our wonderful panel.
A- as well as to our engaged audience.
Policies being shaped today, whether around federal funding, grant structures,
workforce development, or global collaboration, are not abstract.
They
directly influence what science gets done,
who gets to do it, and how quickly discoveries reach patients.
As researchers, you are among the most credible, that's all of you in the audience,
and effective advocates for cancer research.
Your experience, and we've heard from so many of you today. I love the engagement.
Writing grants, running labs, mentoring trainees, and working with patients
brings a critical real-world perspective to policymakers.
They need to hear it. Come back tomorrow when the director is here.
It'll be in a bigger room down the hall.
Our hope is that you leave this session not just with greater understanding of the
policy landscape, I know I am, but with a clearer sense of how
we as a community can help shape the future of cancer research together.
It really has been a pleasure being your moderator today.
The next session will begin in about 15 minutes.
It's Modernizing Non-Clinical Safety Assessment in Oncology
Product Development: Current Progress and Future Directions, led by Haley
Saber of the FDA. Great to have the FDA back, right, this year at this
meeting. But, consider staying and joining us for the
regulatory and policy track. Thank you.
Was proven. I wanted to say that, I think